what's up reject nation I'm Greg I'm
John we just heard the news about
Michael Keaton possibly he's in talks
right now to reprise the role of Batman
in the flash movie directed by Andy
machete and also will be talking about
JK Simmons who's already shot another
installment or something I don't really
know who wore spider-man and there's
some more J Jonas James exactly and
supposedly they're supposed to be a
little bit more of that before we go
into the news though I did want to get
my condolences for the loss of filmmaker
Joel Schumacher we learned that he
passed away I don't know if it was - I
think it was today or at least broke
please the news broke today that he
passed away he did contribute to the
Batman world a lot people don't really
like Batman and Robin but you know
Batman Forever a lot of people really
did enjoy but beyond that the man had
made a lot of really good films some
that were just really great from the 80s
90s and early 2000s films like The Lost
Boys falling down the client - time to
kill Tigerland and phone booth just to
name a few may he rest in peace and
condolences to his family as well maybe
we'll remember all the great films that
he gave us during his time that he was
around and - a lot of the actors and
actresses you really helped boost into
the spotlight so mayhem the random piece
and the bad nips yeah of course but what
we're talking about Batman
I just mean do one thing oh by all means
yes this is this is important yes I got
this mass from touring it what a Greg go
John you wanted to do your joke and you
should have waited for me to stop no
timing you got a note I know time to die
you got a note alright so got this mask
like a year and a half ago from Target
I've been waiting forever for the right
video to wear for oh and I've chosen
today it's really tight it's actually
really difficult to breathe around the
not seen my
no like that the bridge at my nose right
here it's really painful it's
unfortunate that it looks pretty good
from this thank you I mean but man is it
not really uh yeah it's hard to see from
there pushing on my eyeballs so I should
have got it was a dollar if you're ever
gonna play Batman you gotta get used to
this stuff yes this is how Bruce Wayne
feels every night anywho the story broke
I think it broke from Hollywood Reporter
it doesn't matter that's the article
that we're gonna read it from today
let's go into it so last time Keaton
played Batman was a 1992's Batman
Returns
as I'd say 20% of you know most people
don't know that I'm here to drop the
important facts for everyone and educate
the world some people still don't pick
up on sarcasm that's your fault now Ezra
Miller is on board a star as Barry Allen
aka the flash and the feature that will
be directed by it filmmaker Andy mushiya
t but wait there's more if a deal makes
Keaton wouldn't just returned for a
flash but possibly for several other DC
oriented film projects sources tell to
her that the role being envisioned for
veteran actor is akin to the role played
by Samuel Jackson as Nick Fury in the
MCU something of a mentor or guide or
even string-puller Batgirl is one of the
projects and development that could fall
wait a minute okay we got slow this down
alright huh now doing the flashpoint
thing opening up multiverses it's funny
how both Marvel and DC are having that
discussion significantly it seems like
multiverse of madness is supposed to
really open up the multiverse platform
there's still that rumor of Tobey
Maguire reprising his role as spider-man
in the murder room and then now in this
one
flashpoint which has been in development
for such a long time having him returned
I think is really cool that's exciting I
feel like a lot of us have really wanted
to see that to dream I've had for
Michael Keaton to return is if Tim
Burton was like you know what I kinda
want to do my Dark Knight Returns move I
want to just go and do old man Batman oh
let me get Michael Keaton back in the
suit you know I always thought that
would be the perfect way to do it he
obviously can't just da technology has
definitely made the strap I'm excited
that he'll be returned if he's not
wearing a Batman suit but if he's just
brew
Swayne maybe not even Bruce Wayne he's
like in talks for it maybe it could be
like a Thomas Wayne considering that
this will be borrowing from flashpoint
that maybe there's consideration there
you know be cool if we actually got
Michael Keaton to return as Batman but
as thomas wayne honoring flashpoint even
more if you guys haven't seen the DC
animated flashpoint movie which is you
know based on the comic watch the movie
at least it's wonderful one of my
favorite DC animated movies I've ever
done that does sound exciting now this
whole thing about him returning for
multiple projects and being this Nick
feel Nick Fury or or the jekyll/hyde of
this you know that's an even better CC
you need that I don't wait do they need
that I don't feel like they do I don't
feel like they do and I mean they've
already kind of tried doing that with
Justice League the once already because
you know you had Ben Affleck Batman here
guys of course everyone's favorite
character she's gonna be the true Nick
yeah it is odd to me it would make the
most sense for that to happen in my eyes
if they were to do some kind of thing
that pulls in the Batmobile why didn't
you turn off my phone Greg I just I
really want to get to know all your
friends yeah if they introduce some kind
of Batman Beyond thing via flashpoint I
guess that's how I would feel the the
best with a sort of mentor string-puller
Batman because at least that idea is
native to the Batman Beyond storyline
but beyond that just the idea of having
him appear is really cool to me it's the
only kind of eyebrow raiser literally is
that detail well the thing with Michael
Keaton returning is is something that
people have been wanting for a very long
time him to show up in some form one
thing that I think you could really
commend the folks behind the DC films
right now is there are a hundred percent
listening to their faith and this seems
to be another step in that direction of
you know a lot of times we're hearing
fans were constantly clamoring for some
way to have Michael Keaton reprised the
Batman role maybe not a continuation of
the 90s
but do something with him flash point is
it might not be a Batman movie but the
thing what's funny about this concept of
flashpoint did you think that would kind
of steal the spotlight it would be a
because the exciting news is Batman not
really flash yeah I know I mean because
especially that first Batman movie is
like one of the major you know ground
breakers in terms of superhero comic
book cinema and yeah I mean Michael
Keaton is like somebody whose portrayal
people have grown up on for literally
more than one generation now so I do
feel like it would be something that
almost sounds like yeah they don't think
the flash is enough to get people
excited and so some kind of thing like
this I wouldn't expect this to be the
last of these appearances that we hear
are coming in this movie perhaps because
it seems like flashpoint opens you up to
a whole lot of possibilities yeah I
think it could be really cool it remains
to be seen as to how they handle it but
I'm generally more optimistic at the
moment than not if that man because this
is kind of what I've been hoping for
like is the multiverses and the you know
more space time bending storylines come
into the forefront you know there's all
kinds of like wacky fun you can have
bringing characters back and mixing and
matching you know oh I think that with
the all the multiverse discussions that
have been going on I feel like there's
something that's actually more exciting
about the actors reprising their roles
from you know prior installments or the
prior franchise's established with these
characters and then putting them in
these movies because I feel like when
you do like a brand new character you
have to introduce a brand new character
and that could take up time and it could
be distracting and granted this could
also be distracting but at least there's
already the built-in familiarity with oh
yeah Michael key oh it's that order you
know Tobey Maguire spider-man we know
these guys already and now we're just
like doing a really quick catch-up with
who they are him returning in multiple
movies I'm not sure what that is it's
like okay this DC now have a road map
they were taking this like what movie at
a time but if these if they want him to
return in multiple movies to be someone
who like connects multiverses and
whatever maybe they have like an actual
road map now establish where they want
to go with this and
maybe somehow this will link to the
Snyder code if the Snyder code is
successful you know I mean I would be
fascinated to see what that road map
looks like because things like the
Snyder cut are making it a little less
obvious to me because you know they're
clearly gonna go invest in something
that's technically passed for them yeah
it almost feels like they're just doing
anything and whatever seems to be
working yeah which is cool in a way but
yeah I don't quite understand the full
spectrum because it seems like they have
their main universe that's continuing
past you know the success of Wonder
Woman shazam Aquaman then you're going
back for you know the Snyder cut and now
you've got this flashpoint movie which I
can't tell what it's supposed to do is
like I can't tell if it's just supposed
to continue this main continuity or to
become some kind of junction point for
the roadmap like maybe it's the center
of the roadmap or something like that
but I don't know it's at least got me
curious not being as unified at the
moment as Marvel is clearly trying to be
so that's interesting John stop hitting
them against each other Playstations way
better than Xbox that's right it's not
about which games are aware but yeah how
where do you guys think about Michael
Keaton returning to reprise his role as
Batman in the flash do you want that or
do you just want to show up in Robert
Pattinson 'he's batman and make that
really confusing Libre shots nickel slow
oh my god we should get a Jack Nicholson
cameo as a Joker I mean I wouldn't rule
it out and imagine if that was like one
of the last things he did on screen
let's move on now this would be really
short JK Simmons is reprising his role
as Jay jonah Jameson officially and
here's what he said what I thought was
interesting says well yeah I'll be back
as Jameson that's a short answer there
was a future for Jay John Jameson after
several year hiatus he showed up very
briefly for those who are wise enough to
state those credits are far from home
there is one more JJJ appearance in the
game and from what I'm hearing there's a
plan for yet another so hopefully JJJ
will continue now and forever now what I
find interesting about this obviously is
feather they already shot one in advance
so is like that specifically for
spider-man 3 or is it more be imagine
it's probably Morbius right especially
with the fact that they
the murderer signed the the pitcher and
then it will probably see some news
report to help establish that a little
bit better it feels to me like they want
him to be an antagonistic presence yes
spider-man world just going forward or
it could be venom two perhaps bottom
line I mean it's cool that he's coming
back and now I'm wondering though with
Jay jonah Jameson back in here is
Michael Keaton's Batman coming today are
they going to clear things up in this
sense of you know that's JK Simmons from
the Raimi trilogy yeah Lane J jonah
Jameson if he is like already he shot
another one and it's already established
and then yeah the fact that that
spider-man image was the Tobey Maguire
one where it said murder are they gonna
use Jay jonah Jameson actually because a
lot of us are looking at like
spider-verse or multiverse of madness
and their way to bring back Tobey
Maguire but maybe they might use the Jay
jonah Jameson with JK Simmons already
have won out in an MCU movie has another
one shot has more planned maybe he'll
become like an integral character again
and they'll use that in a way to help
establish the tie-ins to like the Raimi
trilogy or whatever because I mean if
he's back in here that's already a sign
that it's tied in oh yeah sure and I
mean it also opens you up not to you
know make everybody some kind of
linchpin for a bigger operation but Jade
case Jay jonah Jameson seems like a
character who could be a foil in a lot
of respects and maybe be in league or at
least in some kind of cahoots with
spider-man's other and Mysterio to be
involved or something because you know
he is here like leaking information and
trying to rile up the public frequently
against spider-man and I could
definitely see that being a just a
looming presence that the other villains
and stuff or just again antagonists in
general are at least involved with or
paying attention to you know huh no see
it's exciting though leave your thoughts
down below
but guys Michael Keaton returning as
that is really exciting honestly like
I'm beriberi
or the reason I wasn't like expressing
that like big level of enthusiasm
earlier is because it's flashpoint and
this movies had so many problems I don't
really get fully convinced is coming out
talks right now the thought of him
returning is like it's really exciting
because it's one of those things that's
like oh that's possible now yeah and it
wasn't before and I feel like yeah what
DC listen to her fans is pretty freaking
cool
alright guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell we'll catch
you guys soon